[Music]
when I was 2 years old my parents
noticed that was not speaking quickly
after the doctors diagnosed me as Duff
for the next 12 years of my life I
learned to speak I spent many Sunday
afternoons with my mother on the bedroom
carpet and she teach me words we call
these sessions words and basically we
will sit there and shoot each meet words
and I would never forget the story that
my mother told me about the first word
I've learned it was the word up she hold
me in her arms and she carry me up and
down the stairs and she said to me
Caroline we're going up up we go
up all my mom's friends and family
thought she was crazy taking on this
grand project but I want to say the word
up
I see how she open and closed her mouth
and closed through the pop finally she
would take my hair and and she would
please to take my hand she place it on
her coat and I feel to the vibrations
what kind of sound to trying to make
finally at the age of two and a half I
said the word back to her up my man when
my mom heard these words she was so
overjoyed she cried tears of happiness I
asked her why did he teach me to speak
instead of teaching me sign language and
he said Caroline because I wanted you to
connect with anyone in this world I
wanted you to introduce herself and say
hello I wanted you to stand in front of
an audience and express yourself and
your ideas not a day goes by that I'm
not grateful for her teaching how to
speak the ability to connect with anyone
is such a privilege I'm able to connect
with anyone I can
and through the positive learning how to
speak I've grown to learn about the
power of the word I'm gonna share a few
short story with you about the power of
the word by the time I was in second
grade I had slowly but surely built up
my vocabulary however although on this
simple side so I had a plan after school
I would review the dictionary it was a
little tedious but I kept reading it and
in the next day or going to class and I
say he's very exploit and complex words
and my I thought I was so impressive but
the teacher would come over and say
Caroline you know why using these words
are they proud of you
but you're not using them correctly I
was embarrassed in a moment but and it's
funny now but when I reflect a pot back
on it I realized sure I used smart and
complex words but they didn't understand
what I was saying and I found time and
time again by using simple words you can
conduct so much more powerfully with
anyone by being simple
you're not dumbing down they've been
smarter with their time and your words
be powerful by being simple words allows
allows us to connect with others but
they also allow us to imagine a future
about two years ago I was skiing down
the slopes of New Zealand that took a
wrong turn and snap I broke three out of
four of my knee ligament it was a very
serious injury and I immediately went
into surgery as I'm exiting the fog of
anesthesia
I see the surgeon staring at me with a
very serious face and she says Caroline
that was a very serious injury
you got to work very hard to walk again
and I remember in that moment thinking
I'm deaf already
like my life is hard enough at this but
he was right it was really hard I would
go to physical therapy not make any
progress I was barely able to bend my
knee and slowly and two days went by as
the week's went by Fela crept into me
what if I never walk again finally after
a lot of existence I met with a sports
psychologist her name was Linda and she
would sit me down and she'd say ok let's
close our eyes let's imagine you walking
again I'm a little bit of a skeptical
person so I'm like what is this exercise
mm-hmm but she would walk me through she
say ok let's imagine you sitting and
getting up imagine you walking imagine
you running feeling glass on your ankles
so I did every day I wake up and Majan
myself doing all these things
and what happened afterwards was amazing
I made rapid progress method took up
therapy I started walking again I was
able to run and everyone were Tumi's
they didn't understand what was
happening except me I knew that the
surgeon had healed my body with the
operation but Linda the sport
psychologist had heal my body with words
I was able to visualize the feature she
gave me a seed of a dream when you think
about how you use words you can either
dress the hardships you had a really bad
injury or you can drunk the future and
address and make up a vision you can do
it for yourselves or for others be
powerful by being informational my last
story is a love story I love to write
love letters I have a whole stack of
them on my desk but I've never really
sent them because I didn't want to creep
out the person I was dating
hmm until I finally met someone last
year who I wanted to send a letter to I
wrote it all in one go and I sent it off
I didn't hear anything I was terrified
but finally I got response back and it
was beautiful and someone once said to
me being in love feels like when you've
lost everything but that has been
returned to you and that's how I felt in
that moment mm-hmm a week later I'm at
this person's house and I see in the
corner a wastebasket and it has all the
drafts of my letter so I decided to deal
with an immature person would do I was
back to this person privacy no I
obviously read them all
I'm embarrassed a that but I've got them
all and I actually learned something
really interesting I'm reading through
these drafts and I know there's
something strange there are all these
really tender and vulnerable words that
were crossed out but when I compared it
to the final letter I received I noticed
that my final letter only had a tender
and vulnerable words and that's where
the beauty of the letter came from be
powerful by saying the lines that you
want to cut out how do you measure a
life you measure a life they're words
words are like seeds when we say them
they float through the air they can
remain a seed or they can grow into
something beautiful words can distance
or they can connect words can harm or
they can heal and words can transform
lives like they have done for me all of
you as you go through this life think
about how we use the power of the word
to connect inspire and to lift up thank
you
[Applause]
[Music]